my name is Peter bad welcome to Friday
with being a face
[Music]
hello speedy how's it going bros and
finally finally welcome back to as you
can see there's a bit of difference in
my background I recently moved in
together with my girlfriend and that's
why I've been delayed with the Friday
from Frieda I'm sorry I'm sorry
everyone in this the final house
competition a fair a chance to I look
actually look through all of them
properly so that's why I took my time
waiting okay Jesus crying I could always
kind of chance me and I come up with two
winners actually because there were so
many like I I couldn't decide and I want
to say I feel bad for not choosing more
because it was a lot of really great
funds so yeah the the two winners are in
no specific order or anything I don't
even know what I'm doing I am doing one
of them is a routing surf I think really
picks up nah that's not what I don't
know it was really just funny
uh here shake him off I always do much
snap to do the things but I never edit
it properly so I just end up looking
like an idiot who snaps around like okay
whatever it here's the video open it now
open it now and close the second winner
and was cinnamon toast can he was like
super perfection no he's like more
professional than me
really funny definitely stood out of the
crowds I definitely think he deserves a
spot as well yes I can check out their
channel I'll leave an annotation here
and here hopefully that doesn't look too
[ __ ] say I go subscribe to their
channels there was about 1700 people who
actually wanted a t-shirt since there
were so many who wanted to win a
PewDiePie giveaway I decided to lower
the prices on the spread shirt shop
so maybe more of you guys can get it
I'll annotate the winners for the tea
should giveaway right there since we're
back with Friday's review by any
dubrow's suggestions for what to do in
Priya not previous/next
I think you're actually okay next
episodes are Friday Friday in a pan I
can't look the wheelspin
I need a share like I was so recently
movie and I'm sitting on the floor late
basically anyway tell me what to do and
I'll probably do anything I'm a [ __ ]
whatever and
so yeah as always we're gonna end this
with mm-hmm
you think you're gonna grow it away I
know you didn't do it last time series
of this all right come on brothers let's
do it for me in three okay one two
[Music]
[Music]